alors deux ans plus tard jour pour jour
il fallait absolument qu'on parle au dr
karl weiss dr weiss bonsoir oui bonsoir
incroyable quand même deux âges que
quand je me remémore toutes les fois et
il fallait plus vous l'avez souvent dit
être humble devant tout ça parce que
même là on va parler de l'avenir mais il
faut on s'est posé pas toujours ce qui
va arriver
oui les prédictions c'est un art on se
trompe toujours alors si on regarde ce
qu'ont pensé il ya deux ans est ce qu'on
a appris entre temps on voit qu'il faut
beaucoup d'humilité à la médecine on a
beaucoup de choses qu'on pensait être
vrai ne sont plus mais ça il faut
toujours avoir cette approche en
médecine sinon vous vous trompez à tous
les coups et puis moi des gens qui m'ont
formé en médecine m'ont formé dans cette
optique là en disant que ce que j'avais
appris quand ils étaient étudiants
s'étaient probablement des huées donc ce
que moi j'ai appris quand j'étais
étudiant en médecine c'est aujourd'hui
désuet et donc il faut avoir une
humilité on s'en va
donc on a appris beaucoup je pense que
la corrida transformer la société a
transformé le monde on est tous on peut
tous se regarder devant un miroir ce
soir et se dire qu'est ce que j'ai
appris durant ces deux dernières années
comment les choses ont changé pour moi
qui est ce qui a pu se changer vous avez
fait aussi des reportages très
intéressant sur malheureusement tous ces
québécois qui nous ont aussi quitté
pendant ces deux dernières années due à
la cowitz et c'est beaucoup de morceaux
de vie de beaucoup de gens qui ont
contribué à faire le québec moderne qui
ne sont plus avec nous aujourd'hui faut
pas oublier que ces gens là ont vraiment
contribué à la société québécoise
moderne c'est cette génération est donc
il ya aussi une perte qui est un peu
irremplaçable de cette copie de là
maintenant et c'est sûr qu'il faut vivre
avec une approche différente pour pour
vivre avec un virus qu'on a donc fait en
quelque sorte qu'ils aient pas encore
totalement apprivoisé bombe alors je
valais avec les questions que les gens
se posent qu'on se pose quelles sont
d'abord est-ce qu'on est sorti de la
pandémie pour arriver dans l'an dernier
à ce qu'on est ce qu'on est sortis
d'après vous
moi je pense que non encore pas tout à
fait mais vous savez il y aura pas une
sortie brutale du jour au lendemain
c'est un peu une sortie qui va être
progressive et c'est comme si vous
voulez l'image on avait déjà ce qu'on
avait fait c'était c'est comme le fleuve
qui se jette dans l'océan l'eau est
douce mais elle devient tranquillement
ça l'est jusqu'au moment où elle est
sale et donc l'endémie ccsa et est donc
on se dira qu on est quelque part à
l'embouchure du fleuve où il ya démarré
mais on n'est pas tout à fait encore
sorti dans l'océan est ce que le variant
dont on parle en europe de l'ouest le
béa 2 vous inquiète vous
la réponse est non parce qu'on en a déjà
au québec on a déjà 25 30% des fois de
nos sources qui peuvent être aidés à 2
alors on est très prévenant déjà dans
notre environnement les gens qui ont
fait au micro son protégé quand le béa 2
donc la réponse claire c'est non bon ça
c'est clair le vde à peu près toutes les
mesures puis demain il y aura d'autres
mesures levé l'ontario ça a été encore
plus vite l'alberta encore plus levée de
toutes les mesures ce que vous estimez
c'est une bonne chose
oui j'estime qu'une bonne chose parce
qu'il faut avancer dans la démarche de
la société le bon côté des choses c'est
qu'on a justement levait déjà beaucoup
de mesure et on n'a pas eu ce scénario
catastrophique au contraire vous voyez
les écoles ont commencé à fonctionner
plus normalement le retour au travail
et on n'a pas eu le scénario catastrophe
au contraire le nombre
d'hospitalisations 10 min une bonne
partie des hospitalisations 40 à 50% de
gens spécialisés avec l'aco vide ne le
sont pas pour la copie on a beaucoup
d'outils aujourd'hui qui sort d'un homme
un en termes de traitement donc oui
c'est une façon aussi d'enlever de la
pression dans la société et puis on a vu
d'autres pays sur la planète où ça a
déjà été fait de façon plus précoce et
où ça va relativement bien donc vous
êtes là aussi optimiste le taux de
vaccination qui est quand même élevé au
canada
très élevé même quand on compare à
d'autres pays le fait que des pays soit
à peu près pas vaccinés qui est donc une
inégalité vaccinale sur la planète
qu'est-ce que ça risque de faire comme
mes fesses dans les prochains mois
alors peut-être quelques points
importants le canada a très bien fait
sur l'aspect du taux de vaccination est
là la médaille il faut pas la donne et
je vous dirai aux campagnes de
vaccination jusqu'à un certain point la
vraie médaille il faut la donner aux
canadiens ou québécois qui se sont en
eux-mêmes en ligne en très grand nombre
pour aller se faire vacciner pourquoi je
vous dis ça parce qu'il ya des endroits
sur la planète qui sont des pays
relativement pauvre où il ya de très
bons taux de vaccination je vous donne
l'exemple vietnam le cambodge dont des
certains pays d'amérique centrale il ya
des pays plus riches comme par exemple
la bulgarie ou la slovaquie qui ont des
systèmes de santé qui sont quand même
pas de mauvais système de santé où les
taux de vaccination sont beaucoup plus
faibles il ya des pays comme le maroc
qui est pas un pays très riche mais pas
un pays très pauvres non plus qu'il ya
des très bons taux de vaccination et
vous avez des pays d'amérique du sud qui
sont aussi bien vaccinés là où ça va mal
c'est en afrique mais en afrique pour
toutes sortes de raisons il ya eu aussi
un certain refus de la voir de la
population d'avoir des vaccins dans
certains pays donc c'est pas que les
vaccins n'ont pas été offerts ou n'ont
pas été disponibles il ya des problèmes
de logistique à l'occasion mais il ya
aussi un espèce de refus de vaccination
donc quand on regarde une carte du monde
c'est clair que l'afrique est moins
vacciner que le reste de la planète mais
ce n'est pas toujours directement relié
je vous dirai au niveau de vie ou au
niveau du service de santé maintenant
qu'est ce que c'est il faut pas oublier
dans toute l'afrique est quand même
population beaucoup plus jeune donc où
la mortalité associée à l'aco vide où
les conséquences hospitalisation de la
colline sont moins marquées que ce qu'on
voit dans d'autres pays de la planète
dans des populations plus mais est-ce à
dire que en apprenant restons en afrique
une seconde continent africain beaucoup
moins vacciner est ce que il vaut quand
même développé son immunité collective
si je peux dire oui alors moi j'aime
plus beaucoup le terme immunité
collective mais on s'entend ce que ça
veut dire on parle d'une certaine ni té
face au virus oui l'afrique va le
développer parce qu'il ya énormément de
cas en afrique qui n'ont pas été
répertoriés mais beaucoup de gens ont
fait la maladie par contre le danger je
vous dirais de tout ça c'est que dans
les populations africaines où il y a des
gens immunosupprimées et on l'a vu avec
l'afrique du sud puisque c'est de là
qu'est venu le vario micron thomas ne
variant précédemment donc on vous avez
ici les éléments pour avoir une
émergence potentiel de souche qui sont
de nouvelles souches dans des
populations qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
vaccination où il ya une je vous dirais
une certaine pauvreté où il ya une
surpopulation en termes de densité de la
population et où il ya des moyens
médicaux qui sont limités dont vous avez
cette espèce de recettes 1 pour avoir
une émergence de variantes qui pourrait
ensuite se propager donc c'est important
de ne finalement aider tout le monde
pour que ça on est dans l'outrance aide
un peu donc vous êtes il faut pas
regarder ailleurs non plus là il faut
accélérer la pression pile entraide pour
que tout le monde soit pas mal vaccinés
pas ça peut nous jouer des tours ici
après le bain on l'a vu avec au micro
regarder l'afrique du sud et on pense
que c'est même pas en afrique du sud en
réalité on pense c'est peut-être au
botswana actuelle au micron a émergé
mais l'afrique du sud est quand même un
pays qui a un système de santé qui est
loin d'être mauvais au contraire avec de
grandes universités en traite entre
autres à johannesburg et au cap et ils
ont été capables donc d'identifier le
virus et le nouveau variant rapidement
on en a dicté un vaccin dont on a dit
invariants sud africain mais
probablement qu'il a émergé dans un
autre endroit de l'afrique que des
migrants endroit meneur afrique du sud
mais regardez à la vitesse au moins de
novembre on parle de micron et à la fin
décembre quasiment toute la planète n'a
que du au micro je peux vous donner un
exemple au québec au micron au début du
mois de décembre c'était même pas 10% de
nos songes la noël le 25 décembre
c'était quasiment 100% de nos souches
donc vous avez vu comment rapidement
dans de quelques temps variant émergeant
d'un autre endroit sur la planète puisse
s'implanter partout je me souviens je
termine avec sa docteur va être le 29
décembre vous m'aviez donner d'entrevue
ça a été beaucoup on en a beaucoup parlé
de celle là parce qu'avec comme une
grande déprime générale et on refermait
tous les gens étaient découragés
littéralement c'est pas vrai on va et
vous vous étiez quand même parmi les
gens qui ont parlé le plus optimiste
j'ai dit oui mi février mi février on va
on voir respirer c'est normal ayant
rythme a tout ce qu'il faut pas paniquer
c'est exactement ce qui est arrivé
oui ce n'est pas que j'étais devin mais
c'est parce qu'on a on a eu un virus qui
est arrivé à envoyer qu'il était
premièrement moins virulent surtout
moins virulent dans une population
vaccinée on avait un très bon taux de
couverture vaccinale de la population
québécoise
donc oui on a observé que ça allait
avoir quelques périodes difficiles mais
que pour l'immense majorité des gens
d'aller passer au travers on a aussi des
médicaments on traiter beaucoup mieux
donc c'est probablement un ensemble de
facteurs qui a fait qu'on est arrivé
finalement à passer au travers mais il
faudra regarder les prochaines vagues de
façon très différente parce que on n'est
plus du tout dans la même dynamique
voilà merci beaucoup dr weiss à bientôt
bonne fin de semaine plaisir qu'on
croirait pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]